Imagine you sit down at your computer
every morning at 7:30 a.m., trade for 60
minutes, and walk away after catching a
massive move done for the day. Today,
I'm going to show you a simple,
repeatable pattern that helps you spot
high probability reversal areas,
allowing you to get sniper entries,
getting you huge reward with a little
bit of risk. If you stick to this simple
strategy, your trading will drastically
change. Now, there's two key things that
I use to easily find where these areas
are. Otherwise, it's really hard to know
exactly in the market where you can
cleanly enter in and where it's going to
have a massive move in that direction.
And the first one of those is properly
identifying supply and demand zones.
It's super easy to go on any chart and
try and look at every little reversal
area the market has, every swing that it
has. And so, how do you properly find
the correct supply and demand zones that
are more likely to have a drastic move
off of them? The way I do this is I boil
it down to a few simple steps. The first
thing I like to do is we'll stick to the
extremes. If you look at just these
swings in the market, the market has all
these back and forth swings. Any asset
you look at and the biggest way to
capture a massive move is either
shorting off of the extreme highs or
betting long off of the extreme lows.
Trying to trade these little middle
areas is just so hard to become
profitable at and you're not going to
get high risk-to-reward ratio trades.
The next thing is using a zone instead
of just a straight line. Because if you
look at it, every time the market comes
up into this area, it bounces in a
different spot. It roughly bounces in
this area, but it's never an exact
science. If you have a specific line
here, well, you might think, oh, it's
broken past and you stop watching for
the day or it reverses too soon and you
don't take a trade. And so treating
things like a supply or demand zone is
extremely important. Now the next thing
as well is I like to look for two
touches in these levels before I confirm
and start paying attention because
otherwise it's potential that you are in
a you know let's say a crazy big uptrend
like we're in right now and you start
saying here's a swing up a down okay so
I'm going to think of this as a level
and you try and short here and instead
it continues higher and so that's going
to help you avoid getting in or trying
to take trades in the wrong areas. It
can take a lot of practice to get these
zones. Now, knowing the correct zones to
pay attention to can be really tricky
sometimes. And so, I actually have
something that an indicator that's free
that will help draw the important zones
of where to pay attention to and where
to look for reversal trades off of. It
helps you kind of avoid that noise in
the middle, the not so good levels, and
when the market kind of gets to
extremes, it helps you pay attention to
those areas that are important. Now, the
second thing that I use to spot clean
reversals in the market, you can see
here that we're looking at 15-minute
chart of gold, and it's actually I have
that indicator that's drawn a big supply
zone down here. And this is actually a
trade I'm currently in right now. But
why I got into this was the market had a
big move into this level. What I've
noticed over time is if we just zoom out
looking at this is anytime the market
has kind of a big move in one direction
like this that's very drastic in one way
is the market will always give that back
up. You can see right here as well.
Market has a big move up here, it sells
off. Big move up here, it sells off. And
it's because if you look at it compared
to the chart and the big thing with this
is you'll notice see the candlesticks
here are really really big compared to
what it was doing before. So it was
before was in this little uptrend. It
actually had a micro little big move up
here and then a pullback and then here
it had a bigger one and then it
continued. It had an even bigger one and
it pulled back. And the reason why this
works is because the market likes to
move in a methodical trend where it has
moves up and moves down. And if it gets
too far in one direction, it has to
correct that. And so here is a great
example where it's moving down in a slow
methodical trend down and then all of a
sudden it starts to go crazy here in one
direction. And so it gets overextended.
I like to think of it as an exhaustive
move or overextension. Think of the
market, it's just kind of cruising along
here and all of a sudden it starts to
sprint in one direction. Well, it has to
take a break. And so it causes the
reversal and the market to snap back in
the other direction. And so at that
point, that's where you want to get in.
You want to get in here where you see
the market start to slow down. Exactly
like this trade I took this morning. If
I go in actually a 5minute chart is
you'll see the market did a big move
down here. Lots of volatility. It
started to slow down and then it made
this double bottom right here. And
that's when I jumped in right here. And
then I bet that the market was going to
go back up. And from there, I like to,
you know, see if it will give this move
back up that it had because if you look
at all of these past moves where the
market kind of gets overextended in one
direction, usually it will give that
move it had back up. And that's where
the easy money is. Now, sometimes right
here, you can see it did have a big move
up and then it gave it back up and it
did continue even farther. That can
totally happen and that's kind of when
you get a massive high riskreward move
where you can get 10x, but those don't
happen all the time. And so that's how
you can start to pick either bottoms or
tops. And there's a super simple way to
do this using what is called a fair
value gap indicator. I have made kind of
my own custom version for it that helps
kind of weed out some of the bad ones or
some smaller ones. But if you look at
it, it helps you easily identify when
it's overextended by making these boxes.
You can easily see, okay, here it's
overextended. Over here it's
overextended. And it's likely, you know,
when you start to get a reversal, it
reverses that. And same thing with the
one today is the market had a little
overextension indicator here and it
pushed up higher. And so it's basically
given that back up. And so that's why at
the moment I have a pretty tight
stop-loss on it because I think well you
know either if it keeps going great but
if it pulls back I kind of want to get
out cuz I think the easy money and the
easy move is finished. If you want to
trade on this platform that I'm using
right here it's called Ninja Trader. You
can get it for free in the description
below or this QR code. And so the last
big trick about this is how do you
actually know when to actually enter? If
I pull up a riskreward calculator here,
depending on where you enter, you can,
you know, if I entered in all the way up
here and had my stop loss all the way up
here, the market has to move all the way
up here for me to get one times my risk.
But if you move that all the way down to
here, that same move is three or four
times your risk. And so this makes how
you enter into these trades extremely
important. It's a balancing act between
having too tight of a stop-loss to where
yeah, if it if it works out perfectly,
you could get, you know, with a tiny
move, you could get a 20x. But in the
reality of trading, that's really kind
of just a fantasy. Trying to go for
something more reasonable like three or
four times your risk is a lot better.
You know, five is great, too. often I
kind of try and just hit kind of 2x as a
easy target and then if things go crazy
I get more when it comes to trading the
way you make a lot of money is your
sizing I'm risking $1,000 per trade a
lot of the time this one's only risking
$500 per trade but when I'm big size
it'll be $,000 or $1,500 and then if it
goes you know 2x well hey it's $2,000
that's plenty of money I don't need to
be making a 10x trade at $200 $1 of risk
to make that because that's a lot harder
to do. And so, let me show you a couple
ways to do this to help maximize your
riskreward ratio. And so first off, big
picture-wise, I always like to look at
on a 15 or 30 minute chart of where are
these major levels, where are the major
reversals going to happen, you know,
when the market comes down to these
levels that I want to be paying
attention to because bigger picture
allows you to focus on kind of the
extremes of catching kind of a top of a
massive potential move. But if you go
down to a five-minute chart, you're able
to get a more accurate entry. And if you
even went down to a one minute chart,
you could have noticed that well the
reversal looked like it was, you know,
there was kind of a double bottom right
here. And so even then the reversal
there could have been a signal to jump
in long right here. And that would have
been way before my 5minut signal. And
that's just, you know, a comfortability
thing for me. I like trading a 5minute
because it's a little slower. But you
can totally trade this on a 1 minute.
And if you did that on a one minute
instead of being up for me, you know,
I'm up one and a half times right now
roughly here. Well, you would have been
up one, two, three times your risk at
that point. And so you can see it looks
like it just stopped me out there. And
that's totally okay. You know, not every
trade is going to be a massive runner
and a massive home run. The idea is that
you are looking for these levels over
and over over time and that using this
strategy will help you target kind of
these lows and reversals. The whole idea
is finding something super repeatable
like this and trading it consistently.
Now, you can get these two indicators
for free in the description below. They
help make it way easier to actually just
kind of sit and wait for the proper
areas to show up instead of constantly
trying to second guess. So, I highly
recommend checking those out. And if you
want a more detailed walkthrough of this
strategy, how to consistently execute
over time, check out this video right
here.
[Music]